hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you guys requested as
soon as it finished uh it is from the
match uh uh cuba versus india two uh
india one and india three are battling
it out on first board uh to see who will
claim the supremacy and defeat a uh
chess olympiad but we're gonna discuss
that at another video uh here we have a
very nice game between uh carlos daniel
buenos cabrera and lucas who is
currently the only player on 100
i believe uh or maybe he's not but he's
definitely the the only player on board
one with 100 score uh he already won six
games in a row and now uh well will he
continue in this fashion uh let's uh
let's check it out but before we check
out the game
i would just like to mention one thing
that in the match that we already
covered one game from wesley seoul uh
played against malcolm yan uh wesley won
that game brilliantly and it seemed like
uh united states were gonna crush
armenia and that's it uh you know
they will will be merely underway to
winning the olympiad if nothing goes
wrong however that didn't happen the
match actually ended in a draw because
uh something so peculiar happened that
almost never happens uh
in the match um uh between uh you know
sam shankland and uh robert
uh shanklin had a a draw it was a dead
draw he knows it's a dead drawing he
just moves his king back and forth back
and forth back and forth
the problem is uh when his opponent
picked up a queen and he played the move
uh shangrin thought that he delivered a
check and he already grabbed this king
the problem is he didn't move his queen
all the way uh and uh shanklin's king
was not in chair so he picked up his
king but there was no good move wherever
he puts the king the game is just
lost
so he picked up the king he looked at
the board and he resigned the game it
was incredible and i just thought i
should mention that there's even a nice
clip of this you can check it out uh
here it is so you can see
shankland is waiting for uh honestly to
make a move he makes a move but he
doesn't make a move all the way with the
queen he thought he's in check
but he's not in check there's no move he
looks at the board if he moves the king
anywhere it's a game over
and of course it was in this position
that sam shanklin resigned the game and
the united states did not win their
match against armenia so truly
incredible i just thought i'd mention
that now let's check out this game uh so
uh carlos daniel abornos cabrera opens
with ponte e4 and lucas replies with c5
uh going for the sicilian defense with
knight f3 knight to c6 and pawn to c3
now going for the elephant variation
repairing d4 and black always strikes
with the d5 when this happens because it
is a chance to get your queen early into
the game since the c3 square is occupied
by the pawn so you don't have to worry
about knight c3 kicking away your queen
so he captures queen captures and now
pawn to d4 knight to f6 and now d
captures on c5 so this is nothing new
all been played before queen capture 71
king captures and ponte e6 now preparing
to win back the pawn so b4 defending the
pawn and now black of course goes after
this uh queen set expansion with a5 uh
attacking the flank here so b5
challenging the knight and now there are
a couple of games that read this
position but
exclusively knife the b8 was played here
here instead of knight b8 knight the e7
is played by gokush and it is now as of
nine that we have a completely new game
and already uh a very big decision for
uh for carlos daniel uh to make if he
doesn't want to be worse or straight out
of the opening and here uh you have to
continue with something like knight beat
d2 or knight after d2 uh and
just to give you an example uh let's say
we play this we're going to play knight
e to d5 now and now uh attacking the c3
pawn so c4 attacks the knight allows
this check now comes king to c2 and now
the point is knight c to e4 you go after
the c5 pawn and the f2 pawn and white
will of course have to give up one of
them captures characters you're going to
defend your e3 pawn and now black is uh
able to recapture with bishop captures
on c5 in the game continues uh probably
there should be two captured uh
characters characters and it's a
perfectly fine position for both white
and black uh however in the game after
97 knight the e5 was played here
preparing c6 right away now it seems
like it's uh it's it's a possibility to
create a passport right away
but this is uh harder than it seems with
knight the g6 offering a trade of
knights so here uh we have a trade
captures captures and the bishop to e3
now defending the c5 pawn but not
knights the g4 there's really no good
way for you to
keep this bishop here so c6 creating a
pass pawn b captures b characters and
now knight captures on e3 we have f
characters on e3 and bishop to a6 so
here um
white is still up uh up upon but it's
going to be very hard to keep it and you
have three very very weak pawns here so
knight to d2 uh continuing development
bishop characters uh knight captures and
now rook the h5 getting the rook into
the game going for uh these pawns here
uh knights the g3 attacks the rook and
now first rook to e5 challenging the e3
phone so rook to e1 defending and now
comes bishop to d6 uh we broke the b1
and now we just
rook to a6 go after this pawn here so
king to c2 there's really no good way to
keep the spawn and rook captures on c6
so it took bookish while some 21 move
but he now regains the material balance
and he has a better position as he only
has two pawn islands uh his opponent has
four pawn islands and that's a pretty
big issue as there are four more rooks
in the game so pawn to e4 and now rook
to c7 not allowing a rook lift with rook
to b7 we have rook to e3 as you know
that uh
is coming for the c3 pawn and now king
is seven we've broke the d3 now come to
rook e to c5 putting pressure on the
pawn here 92 defending the pawn and now
bishop to e5 adding another attacker
here so g3 for the moment the pawn is
nicely defended now come to rook the c4
going after the e4 pawn and now rook e3
so this look kind of stuck here
guarding the two pawns
we have bishop back to d6 uh and now
comes king to d3
now we've rooked a4 going after the a
two pawn now comes knight to c1 we have
pawn to g5 and now rook to b5 going
after the pawn here so f6 goku defends
it and now king back to c2 so not all
that much for white to do other than uh
see how lukas is planning to break
through here so bishop to e5 again uh
piling up on the c3 pawn with king to b3
and now rook a back to c4 now three
pieces attacking that c to pawn so 92
defending and now ponta a4 the king is
now in check king to c2 and now g4 so
grabbing more and more space away from
uh from the white pieces and the white
king we have rook to b6 and now comes
pawn to g5 we broke back to a6 and now
the ship to d6 now again
uh
what can you play here is white not not
a lot of active moves came to d3 you
just have to repeat now pawn to a3 the
pawn is nicely defended here and you
have taken away one more square from the
white pieces upon the e5 here white is
uh
really struggling to find the move that
allows him to
either stay active or stay you know uh
or keep defending everything so he tries
e5 it messes up the pawn structure
and maybe he can do something with it so
f captures an e5 now comes rook to a5 uh
maybe trying even to give up uh
some uh a rook for for now this bishop
and the pawn and maybe you can go after
these spawns but just king f6 here
google doesn't even allow that rook to
b5 and now king to f5 activating the
king we have knights the d4 with check
as the e5 pawn is spinned king f6 knight
back to e2 saying okay maybe black has
nothing better than to repeat king f5 uh
knight to d4 but now comes rook to a4
knife to see one and now point the e4
with check and here luka she's saying
okay if you capture this one then i'm
winning this one and then this one
basically if rook captures on e4 you
just trade captures characters who
captures here attacks the knight and
once the knight moves you go after the
knight and pick up the a2 pawn that's
the idea kb3 rook captures now you have
a past eight three pawn and you should
be able to win this however in the game
uh king the c2 was played and now we
have rook 8 to c4 again piling up on the
c3 pawn and here your last chance to
keep defending is just to continue with
king to b3 however in the game uh
with with rook to b3 sorry but in the
game king the b3 was played and it seems
like maybe you can play this maybe
you're even you know
doing something but now the game is just
over so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the move that
forces bl uh white to resign on the spot
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
instant brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
bishop to f4 look at this bishop to f4
easy to miss but now that you see it of
course uh you see that once you capture
the bishop those pawns are just monsters
and you can't just ignore the bishop so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are a true master of sporting
difficult moves in an end game
uh so here you have the character but
after g captures an f4 it was also in
this position 46 that carlos daniel
alvonas cabrera resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
if you don't uh if you move the rook
then the knight just hangs if you defend
the knight with the rook then we simply
uh pick up the c3 pawn i mean once once
this pawn falls away to check if the
game over there is no way no way to play
this uh and of course if you accept the
bishop then just g captures on f4 and
yes for the moment white is up a piece
but only for the moment as soon as this
rook moves rookie one we cannot run c3
with check and then we pick up the
knight as well as the king does not have
access to the b2 square so king a4 real
captures the rook characters now for or
even better we can go rogue captures on
e4 and now rook to a7 with check king
the b3 rule b1 check we force the rook
trade here captures captures and now e5
and of course the game is completely
winning for black so both of them know
this so after this bishop therefore it's
interesting that he didn't resign here
he first captured it and then he
resigned but some people do this i've
seen this happen in in real life
uh so yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
this
means that
is now on seven out of seven and he is
well uh on his way to maybe just maybe i
don't know if this is possible uh i i'm
pretty sure it has never been done but
uh he might be able to finish the
olympia with a perfect score on board
one there are four more games i don't
know who he's playing against in the
next round
uh but if he somehow pulls uh an 11 out
of 11 then i believe that will be a
result uh unlike uh
any other that uh you know we we've this
even discussed in in a very long time uh
sorry truly remarkable uh for good care
seven out of seven on board one really
uh rigging those points for for team
india too now we'll see how they
continue the entire team uh played well
uh they defeated cuba three and a half
to half so that's pretty incredible
we're gonna discuss some other games as
well but there are so many interesting
ones being played so please do use
hashtag suggestion as that way i also uh
come across the more interesting games
uh without having to check all of them
uh personally uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh and
the short video on on sam shanklin just
picking up the king i mean who does that
no one does that i mean in an olympiad
in such an important game where your
team is winning and then you just become
the king without having to pick up the
king i mean
incredible stuff
but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely played by
lukas beautiful preparation beautiful
you know execution everything just you
know going his way he's truly a
remarkable player
uh so hope he hope he can take it all
the way uh i would like to thank derek
king felix daffo christian what about
him casey vance and braxton reynolds for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day